digamos que tenemos un enorme lago
congelado más o menos algo así el punto
es que se entienda que es una superficie
y que sea plana y que sea de hielo la
idea del hielo ahorita lo vamos a
platicar y es esencialmente que tiene
que ver con la fricción que que puede
ejercer sobre cualquier cuerpo que se
encuentra encima y digamos que tenemos
dos bloques de hielo un primer bloque de
hielo aquí ok y otro bloque de hielo por
acá ahí tenemos nuestros dos bloques de
hielo y digamos que estos bloques de
hielo son exactamente iguales excepto
por una cosa bueno vamos vamos a ir
escribiendo digamos que ambos tienen la
misma masa es decir ambos tienen de masa
digamos cinco kilogramos muy bien y la
única diferencia que va a haber entre
estos dos bloques de hielo es que éste
va a estar en un estado estacionario es
decir está en reposo en reposo o
estacionario ok mientras que éste se va
a mover
a velocidad constante velocidad
constante muy bien y no sé pues podemos
suponer que este se mueve a una
velocidad
digamos hacia la derecha ok y digamos
que su velocidad su rapidez es de 5
metros por segundo entonces por supuesto
su estado estacionario de velocidad
constante es con respecto a nuestro lago
así que ahora vamos a suponer que la
fricción es despreciable y por eso le
pedimos que sea de hielo verdad como es
nuestra idea más intuitiva que tenemos
de cosas que tienen muy poca fricción
así que vamos a suponer que aquí no hay
fricción que la fricción es de expresa
despreciable entonces qué es lo que nos
dice la ley de newton que es
esencialmente este cuerpo de aquí este
este cubo de hielo tiene una velocidad
cero verdad y es constante está en
reposo es estacionario mientras que el
otro cubo de hielo tiene una velocidad
constante de 5 metros por segundo ok el
punto es que ambos tienen velocidad
constante
entonces si nosotros queremos que se
mantengan en ese mismo estado no debe
haber una fuerza neta o más bien su
fuerza neta que estén ejerciendo se
sobre cada uno de estos cuerpos debe ser
cero verdad para que mantengan ese
estado y entonces si uno piensa que en
realidad estos cuerpos pues no viven en
un espacio abstracto en realidad viven
en la tierra verdad entonces tú dirás
oye si estos cuerpos viven en la tierra
entonces debe haber una fuerza de
atracción hacia el centro de la del
planeta que es conocida como la gravedad
verdad entonces
entonces si están en la tierra tu puedes
decir oye pero estos están descansando
en su estado bueno esto está en estado
de reposo o este está en estado de
movimiento rectilíneo uniforme verdad
están descansando entonces yo te
preguntaría bueno cuál es la fuerza que
evita que caigan al centro de la tierra
porque aquí hay una fuerza que va hacia
abajo y es la fuerza de gravedad de
hecho esta fuerza es exactamente la
misma para estos dos cuerpos esta fuerza
es igual a la masa que damos que era la
masa y esto es de 5 kilogramos por la
gravedad por la gravedad entonces esta
gravedad por supuesto sabemos que es de
9.81 metros por segundo sobre
9 puntos y 9.8 digamos metros sobre
segundo cuadrado entonces más o menos si
hacemos este cálculo tenemos 5 por 9 ok
sería 5 por 9 pero antes hay que hacer 5
por 8 son 40 verdad y llevamos 4 y 9 por
5 son 45 y 4 son 49 49 vamos a dejarlo
como 49 newtons esta fuerza de gravedad
es de 49 newtons el peso de este cuerpo
es de 49 minutos y que será igual al
cuerpo al perdón al peso de este otro
cuerpo ok entonces si si tenemos esa
fuerza que está jalando hacia el centro
de la tierra yo preguntaría cuál es la
fuerza que está evitando que se vayan al
centro de la tierra en caída libre y
entonces tú día debes de estar pensando
muy bien en esta respuesta y
esencialmente es que el hielo el hielo
de esta superficie provee una fuerza que
contrarresta a la fuerza de gravedad es
decir hay una fuerza que va hacia
y va que va hacia arriba y que
contrarresta la que ya teníamos es decir
tenemos una fuerza de 49 newtons pero
que va en sentido contrario a la fuerza
de gravedad verdad aquí también tenemos
una fuerza que va hacia arriba y que
también es de 49 newtons muy bien y por
supuesto si tú me dices que existe esa
fuerza tienes toda la razón ahora la
segunda ley de newton sigue siendo
válida porque estas fuerzas aunque si
están ejerciendo se sobre este cuerpo en
realidad no son desbalanceadas más bien
están balanceadas se cancelan se anulan
ok entonces la segunda ley de newton
sigue siendo válida y esta fuerza es lo
que se le conoce como la fuerza normal
ok entonces esta es
fuerza normal y que esencialmente tiene
que ver con bueno se le dice normal
porque justamente es perpendicular a la
superficie en donde nos encontremos por
ejemplo si tenemos no sé que nuestro
objeto nuestro digamos nuestro cubo se
encuentra sobre un plano inclinado
digamos algo así digamos que aquí
tenemos nuestra cajita que nuestra
cajita se encuentra sobre este plano
inclinado entonces la fuerza normal va a
ser una fuerza que imprime la superficie
de forma perpendicular a ella misma
aunque entonces ésta es una fuerza
perpendicular y por eso es que se les
llama fuerza normal y todo esto lo que
hay alrededor de la fuerza normal no es
otra cosa más que una fuerza
electromagnética y ahorita vamos a ver
porque digamos que hacemos un zoom en
sobre bueno cerca de de esta de dónde
está el contacto digamos y aquí tenemos
nuestras moléculas de agua de este de
este bloque de hielo y aquí tenemos las
moles
de agua de la superficie de nuestro lago
congelado ok entonces esto es en donde
se está realizando una fuerza
electromagnética déjenme dibujar estos
digamos como en un vamos a hacerle zoom
vamos a acercarnos mucho más digamos que
aquí tenemos nuestra molécula de oxígeno
y que aquí están nuestras moléculas de
agua muy bien digamos este es una
molécula de nuestro bloque de hielo
mientras que aquí está una molécula de
agua
una molécula de agua de nuestro lago
entonces lo que está ocurriendo aquí en
digamos en a nivel microscópico es que
entre estas moléculas hay una fuerza de
repulsión electrostática muy bien bueno
hay una fuerza de repulsión entre estas
moléculas y eso es lo que está evitando
que nuestro cubo de hielo descienda en
caída libre hacia el centro de la tierra
ok eso es lo que evita que el cubo caiga
hacia el centro de la tierra y es la
repulsión entre las moléculas de agua
muy bien de estos dos objetos entonces a
nivel macro lo vemos como una fuerza de
contacto pero a nivel microscópico oa
nivel atómico simplemente es una
repulsión electrostática